want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you two you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how billionaires think and get some
success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with advice
number one stay within your expertise
with bill gates the biggest impact a
company can have is staying within its
area of expertise
so
you know to make sure that
the education systems around the world
that they get good software and we have
a donation program where we've done
called it's called partners and learning
we have deals with 132 countries how we
grant them software and fund teacher
training in each of those countries so
microsoft's main thing will be about
that library access that school access
the free software the training you know
the job skills and the partners that are
in that
country
uh not not
not so much health care and
whereas the big drug companies we need
to get them into the health care issues
and the banks we need to get into micro
finance and the food companies we need
to get into micronutrients and buying
the output of the farmers in these poor
countries so that
their economies get going so i think
everybody's got a big role to play
but it's it's going to be fairly
centered on the thing that that the
employees know and
uh drives their their specific
contribution advice number two live in
the moment with oprah winfrey gwendolyn
brooks wrote a poem for her children
it's called speech to the young
speech to the progress toward
and she says at the end live not for
battles one
live not for the end of the song
live in the along
she's saying like art eckhart tolle that
you have to live for the present you
have to be in
the moment
whatever has happened to you in your
past has no power over this present
moment because life is now
but i think she's also saying be a part
of something
don't live for yourself alone
this uh this is what i know for sure
in order to be truly happy
you must live along with and you have to
stand for something larger than yourself
because life
is a reciprocal exchange to move forward
you have to give back
and to me that is the greatest lesson of
life
to be happy you have to
give something back advice number three
consider the pros and cons with elon
musk i think fully considered cost
actually just means that if there are um
you want to look at both the benefits
and the cut the cost actually so if uh
if in um sequestering carbon removing it
from the
atmosphere oceans uh
uh it has has some
have some environmental
impact
which might be small but it's not
negative that certainly needs to be
taken into account um
and uh
uh and then by the same token if uh
what's done is
in extracting carbon is a useful product
sure that from which you can generate
revenue then that should count too right
so
i know i'm just sort of saying for
argument's sake like let's say
uh you could create um
you know um
construction material like you know um
cement cement yeah yeah which we just
i'll talk about that later some kind of
useful rocks that are rocks that are
useful or sand or i don't know yeah um
something that's useful for construction
um then uh you could say okay well this
is what we could sell it for and uh
you know and then
just fully consider pros and cons and
and and say okay this is what
you know if um
if we need to pay to have it done in the
future which we probably will have to do
then
um
what's the what's the lowest net cost
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there advice number four allow yourself
to wander with jeff bezos i like time
i don't i'm not efficient with my time
uh
because efficiency
there's an embedded efficient there's an
embedded assumption
when you're being efficient and the
embedded assumption is that you know
where you're going
and i like to wander
because it's wandering that allows you
to invent and to explore and to follow
your curiosity but wandering is very
time consuming
and so if i could have one more thing it
would just be more time advice number
five don't look for the formula with
mark cuban do you think there's a proven
formula that if a brand rookie guy he's
got a lot of ambitious gun out of this
but not a lot of knowledge on how to do
you think if he follows a formula he's
guaranteed to make it as an entrepreneur
no no okay so you don't believe there's
a guarantee to make it no because who
knows who you're going to be competing
with so if you put two two people both
following the same formula both in the
same industry right which one wins you
know maybe they both can win and both be
successful but you know so i don't i
don't think there's a default default
template for success but i think there's
things that you can do to put yourself
in the best position to succeed you know
so i talk about stuff in the book you
know i talk about the one thing in
business you can control his effort
you know um going out there and sales
curing all you know so i i think you
know and i agree with your point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know a buzz saw and somebody
else is doing them a little bit better
you know what happens advice number six
transcend what's traditional with vinod
khosla what transpired for me when i was
probably 15
was reading in the late 60s about the
founding of a company called intel craig
barrett the ceo of intel is here
and it developed as a role model for me
of what i wanted to do
of course at that stage
of my life it seemed very very far away
but
many years later
and i'll tell you later that i'm a big
fan of risk
i learned hang gliding
and while watching a movie about hang
gliding
i saw this quote
this dedication of the movie and it went
something like this
dedicated to those who dare to dream the
dreams
and then are foolish enough to try and
make those dreams come true
in the operative word here is foolish
because unless
you transcend what's traditional and i
think we've talked about this earlier
unless you go past what's reasonable
you're not going to get
some place
different
most people do the traditional thing and
get to traditional places
there is another way and advice number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is build a team with
grant cardone people are like oh bigger
is not better and you know i'm better
off by myself you are not better off by
yourself it is absolutely impossible to
live on planet earth as one person
try to communicate the seven billion and
think you're going to stay in the game
you're not it's impossible so you
solopreneurs out there
your business model that you created is
already broken thinking i'm going to be
by myself and do it by myself
and the proof is in the pudding because
there's 28 million small businesses in
america 22 million of them uh break even
or lose money those 22 million all have
one thing in common
no employees no support
the best advice i could give is number
one be prepared for a lot of rejection
if you're ready for rejection of people
say no i don't want it no it's not going
to work no this is crazy whatever if
you're prepared for it it's not going to
let you down learn from your failures i
had a lot of failures along the way even
with my patronum paul mitchell but we
learn from those things and we get a lot
better when god created this planet
he created several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say god for now
so i don't have to say the god the
forest god the forest let's just say god
right now god creates a planet earth and
first of all he creates which a lot of
people in different organizations want a
perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of
there's no extra imagination necessary
it's all going to be given to you so he
creates the oyster he says oyster i'm
giving you a free house to live in i'm
calling it a shell i'm gonna put at the
bottom of the ocean
to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the food you
want protection
everything you want the perfectly taken
care of while you're in your measly
little life as an oyster but you're not
going to go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom of the
ocean but you totally got your free food
free clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle you want a house you go out and
build it
take the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed the jung
did you know the eagle fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey they're wild they shoot off in
a different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does it succeed to do
it succeeded to be the strongest bird in
the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into the
thermals of a hurricane and ride them to
have fun
now the eagle unlike the oyster can go
anywhere it wants anywhere it wants yeah
gambles it does this on its own but it
goes wherever it wants
now that eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
and also on the flag of many many
countries you wouldn't be in this room
right now if you weren't eagles don't
only imagine start doing it thank you
peace love and happiness to all of you
thank you very much thank you
within a year of going public i think uh
there's some fortune cover that says the
deal that made bill gates 360 million or
some weird thing like that right how did
it change your life or it didn't change
your life at all well that whole period
of time was amazing because
i was hiring people as fast as i could i
brought in steve ballmer who was very
good at that and and he was helping out
you know we had a sense of urgency that
we wanted to lead the way
there was this graphics interface thing
with windows that we wanted to do so i
was super busy
and the idea that i could
hire so quickly and invest and build
this worldwide company
it was fascinating to me but i was
really busy so you know if some friend
had tried to call me uh you know i i
wouldn't have had too much time for that
i was really into building this company
and i was
going out and telling people about the
magic of software which was good for
microsoft but also helping them
understand the opportunities and the
huge change agent that software and
eventually software plus the internet
would
would become so i was having fun it was
amazing but i always thought hey
you know we're one step away from not
you know leading here we gotta gotta
keep doing better i would say the most
of the opportunity to make computers
improve work is in front of us instead
of behind us
only at kind of a very mechanical level
of
uh it's better than whiteout
uh
you know are we like oh wow this thing
helps me get my work done uh for
extremely structured tasks like creating
financial statements you know where the
application logic is very opaque and
you're just led through it or for very
horizontal things where you
really understand what you're up to and
the machine doesn't see
oh that email is part of personnel
review that email is part of planning
the uh the salesforce meeting so we have
kind of the the low-level horizontal
which in this way is
amazing and then we have this very
structured applications world
the idea of of
matching
what you and your head have as the
intention of the overall activity in the
semantics around it
uh and therefore sort of maximally
helping you with those things i think
now
uh that a lot of base level things are
are done very well including gathering
the data and learning from it that we
should be able to
have what the machine thinks you're up
to and what you think you're up to match
each other
uh and
improve the productivity quality quality
quite dramatically but it's amazing it's
taken a long time to get to this
uh this point and everybody has a
different talent
and the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's talent
and wishing you had some of their talent
all the energy that you spend thinking
about wishing about being jealous of
envious of anybody else is energy that
you're not only putting out is going to
come back to you negatively but you're
taking that away from you
all your energy should be forced on what
do i have to offer what do i have to
give how can i be used in service
because dr king's message of not
everybody can be famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service and
there is not a job in here that you can
do that you don't switch the paradigm to
service
and not make that job more fulfilling i
don't care what the job is if you say
i'm a singer i'm a dancer i'm an artist
i'm a teacher i'm a nurse i'm a doctor
i'm a janitor i'm a i'm a clerk but if
you say if i look at this from how do i
use this in service to something bigger
than myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world and the way i tend
to view problems this is from a from a
physics
standpoint and i think i think physics
is a good analytical framework
um
and one of the key things in in physics
is to reason from first principles
this is contrary to the way most human
reasoning takes place which is by
analogy
um
reasoning from first principles just
means that you you figure out what what
are the fundamental
what are the fundamental truths or or
things that are pretty people are pretty
sure are fundamental truths
and and can you build up to a conclusion
from from that uh or you know from those
principles and uh
and then certainly if you come up with
some idea and it appears to violate one
of those
fundamental
truths then you're probably wrong
or you should get a really big prize or
something like that
so
this may seem like i don't know maybe it
may seem sort of obvious when it's
explained but it's actually not what
people do
reasoning by analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut yeah um
and and it's and it's mostly correct but
but uh it tends to be most incorrect
when you're dealing with new things
because it's hard to analyze to
something really new you started with a
much smaller rock at the top and one
and was your goal at that point when you
started with falcon one to get to the
point where we had nine engines for
falcon 9 was that your goal at that time
when i started spacex i i only thought
there was maybe a 10 chance of getting
felt than one to always i did not at all
think that this would happen uh so this
is for sure our dream come true um
uh but i i literally at the time i
didn't know anything about rockets uh
and i was you know i've been the chief
engineer of spacex since day one and i
don't hear anything about rockets which
is why the first three rockets failed
right um and then
so the first three falcon ones for space
actually failures yes and then
tell me about uh
the fourth one so i had actually only
had enough money for three of three
flights um so i had no more money they
have to manage to
the team sort of rallied and we managed
to put together enough spare parts to
create a to do a fourth launch and that
both launch was successful
and
[Music]
so what would have happened if it wasn't
successful oh we would just basically
die so we would not be here right now
at this moment getting ready to launch
crew dragon to the international system
this work-life harmony thing is what i
try to teach young employees actually
and senior executives at amazon too but
especially the people coming i get we're
asked about work-life balance all the
time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because it
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and um and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody
paying attention to you want to have you
never want to be that guy and we all
know we all have a co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all the
energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy so
you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step we
all get um gifts
uh
we get certain things in our life that
are um
that we're very lucky about and one of
the most powerful one is who your early
role models are you know you could they
could it was your grandfather it was in
a big sense my mom and dad but my
grandfather too
and
you know i had my mom had me when she
was uh
17 years old and she was still in high
school in albuquerque new mexico and
this is in 1964. i can assure you that
being a pregnant uh teenager in high
school was not cool in albuquerque new
mexico at that time
and uh
so
it's in in so it was very it was
difficult for her my grandfather went to
bat for her when they tried to kick her
out of school and you know he
they're they're incredible i had so the
gift i had is i had this incredible
family a lot of startups complained that
they never get the money from banks
never get money from the other venture
capitalists
well rejected by banks
rejected by your venture capital is very
normal
you got money from these guys not normal
why people want to help you
right
there's no reason people help you
you get help because
you earn the credit
you earn the repetition
so
borrow money
from your friends
families that's the sec first step as
everybody if you cannot even borrow
money from your friends and relatives
you gotta have a problem
nobody trusts you
right
so i heard you bottle through two
thousand one thousand dollars that's
good that that means
you
have
this trust
from those people that around you at
least you got somebody
ted williams wrote a book called the
science of hitting and ended he had a
picture of himself at bat and the strike
zone broken into i think 77 squares
and he said if he waited for the pitch
that was really in a sweet spot he would
bat 400 and if he had to swing at
something on the lower corner he would
probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in i can look at a
thousand different companies and i don't
have to be right on every one of them or
even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing
is just to sit there and watch pitch
after pitch go by
and wait for the one right in your sweet
spot and if people are yelling swing you
bum ignore them
there's a temptation for people to act
far too frequently in stock simply
because they're so liquid
over the years you develop a lot of
filters and i do know what i call my
circle of confidence so i i stay within
that circle
and i don't worry about things that are
outside that circle defining what your
game is where you're going to have an
edge
is enormously important the allowance
when i was a little boy was a nickel a
week but i like the idea of
having a little more than a nickel a
week to work with and i went into
business very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold saturday
in post liberty magazine ladies home
journal you name it
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss
that's one thing i like about delivering
papers
[Music]
i could arrange the route i wanted
nobody was bothering me at five or six
in the morning
[Music]
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny turned into something else
there's this culture in silicon valley
that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting a startup
and
my goal when i realized that i had a
company was to get it to be a good
company as quickly as possible where i
didn't kind of get out of what you'd
call the like risky startup phase where
you are just like constantly about to
die and where you could get to a point
where you can actually do some
interesting things and make make a lot
of more interesting bets
and um
so i don't know i never read a lot of
the literature on this and i mean maybe
if i had then i wouldn't have made so
many mistakes but so i don't know if
like if learning for me is the right way
to go on this but i mean but it did
i think your model must have come from
somewhere though even if it was even if
you it was unintentional right like were
you influenced by peter thiel or sean
well yes people see all these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before i'm
talking about
yeah right yeah but he was massively
influential on my thinking right i mean
i like a lot of the
uh the early lessons that i took on how
to think about strategy came from peter
and sean and um i did pay a lot of
attention when i was growing up to
microsoft i thought i mean i grew up you
know using you know windows 3.1 and then
windows 95 and i just thought that those
were like the most unbelievable things
and in that sense they are yeah they
really were awesome right um well i
don't know if you you meant that
positive positively but i did um and
and i thought you know building this
ecosystem was really neat and that kind
of inspired me right in the way that
they built a platform i kind of thought
okay well maybe one day you know that
the tools that i'm building can be part
of a broader ecosystem as well you know
i kind of think about what we're doing
today
um very similarly to how i thought about
where we were at the beginning you know
it's uh you know i get people all the
time who come to me and say all right
well you're investing billions of
dollars in trying to
put internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
um it's not something that uh will that
we'll make any money from for a very
long period of time if it works out but
you know it's this deep belief that
you're trying to make a change you're
trying to connect people in the world
and i really do believe that if you do
something good and if you help people
out then eventually some portion of that
good will come back to you and you may
not know up front what it's going to be
but
that's just been the guiding principle
for me in the work that we've done
everyone thinks that spanx actually
started when i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose but the truth is it started
many many years before that it started
when i was selling fax machines
door-to-door
getting kicked out of office buildings
day in and day out and i woke up one
morning and i thought
i'm in the wrong movie
how did this happen this is not my life
cut scene call the director call the
producer no and i took out a piece of
paper and i wrote down what i was good
at
and there was not much on the page the
word i saw the word sales i knew i was
good in sales so i wrote down in my
journal
i want to invent a product that i can
sell to millions of people
that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea
and i waited for two years
and the idea showed up
and the minute i cut the feet out of my
pantyhose i decided to pursue it
so
what do you do when you have an idea and
you've never taken a business class or
worked in fashion or retail
i wanted to patent my idea
and i ended up
looking for a female patent attorney and
i called the georgia chamber of commerce
and they said there actually wasn't a
single female patent attorney in the
entire state of georgia
so i looked in the yellow pages and
found three men's name and went out and
pitched my idea to them and they
actually thought the idea was so bad
that one of the patent lawyers later
admitted to me he thought i'd been sent
by candid camera
which makes sense because he was looking
around the room for the hidden cameras
but he ended up eventually helping me i
went to barnes noble bought a book on
patents and trademarks wrote my own
patent
and went back to him and said please
please will you just write the claims
portion of it and he did for a
discounted price
but it makes me think about inventors
and innovators and when you hear those
words do you think of women
last year my son
had inventor week at his school and they
asked me to come and be the keynote
speaker at his kindergarten class
so
i was the inventor that was coming and i
started out looking at all these cute
little kids and i said so what does an
inventor look like
and all their hands shot up and one kid
said it's a man and he has crazy hair
and somebody else raised their hand and
said no no no it's a bald man
no it's a tall man it's a short man and
i just stopped and i said
well i'm an inventor
and their eyes got really big and they
said you are
and it dawned on me i looked around the
room and all the pictures of inventors
were albert einstein thomas edison steve
jobs so i can see why the the young girl
who asked me and said i didn't know
girls could be inventors was surprised
and even my son on the way home he goes
mom you're an inventor
but the real point of all of this was i
wanted to help women and i'm so
passionate about it and it's amazing
that i started with their butts and i've
continued to groan i started at the
sarah blakely foundation because i truly
believe that the world would be a much
better place if the male and female
energy on the planet was more balanced i
always ask everybody in the company to
think outside of the box to be very
innovative i like to stop people and say
if nobody showed you how to do your job
how would you be doing your job
just sit with that thought
and
i'm basically a case study of someone
who did not know how it was supposed to
be done i mean no one had shown me i'd
never taken a business class
so
i i find there's so much
amazing you know creativity that will
surface if you stop and get off the
autopilot that we're all on everybody's
doing something because somebody else
showed us how to do it but if you really
want to create big change in the world
or in your life it's going to happen
when you do it differently or you take a
risk to do it different than how the 50
people or 100 or thousand people before
you did it so really encouraging
thinking that way with inside the
company and as we grow still remaining
entrepreneurial having fun
my dad busted his ass i mean he worked
six six days a week um lit left at seven
at seven seven thirty in the morning got
back at six or seven o'clock
lost his eye in an accident doing
upholstery he had a staple break when he
was putting
some
covering on a car seat
you know it was it was a middle class
uprinking my mom did odd jobs
you know they they just wanted something
better i mean my grandparents came over
from russia and you know my dad was the
first generation my uncles were the
first generation americans like my mom
too and
you know like every child of immigrants
they wanted better for their kids you
know it's funny i mean a lot of people
grow up that way right but not many
people end up like you so what do you
think that's the result of
i think
you know
everybody's got something that they're
good at and the hard part is just
finding it and i found out earlier that
i was a good salesperson that i really
liked business you know like i like
sports i mean i read everything i
possibly could played sports as much as
i could just wasn't as good as i wanted
to be and and business was the same way
i mean as long as i could remember i was
buying and selling baseball cards
garbage bags
whatever i could find stamps
um to collectors
but i was also reading everything i
possibly could about business and you
know i was that unusual kid that i'd
rather read about ted turner than go to
the movies and and so i think that
created a foundation of my parents you
know my dad used to always say i don't
understand what you're doing
but i'm glad you're doing it and and so
i have my ups and downs along the way of
course but um i just think that i just i
just put in the time and was fortunate
enough to really get excited about
business and that paid off benefits over
the long haul but you've never been shy
to speak up in issues that are important
to you and one of those themes i've
found has been around fairness and
whether that's you know calling out
referees for not calling games
consistently or
you know calling out a shark tank
contestant because you think that
they're scamming their customers how do
you decide what you're going to speak up
on or do you hold inside you know it's
changed over the years um because i have
kids
because social media you know twitter in
particular is so much different um and
it's changed kind of the rules of
engagement
um it's changed because of what i went
through with the mavericks last year i
missed a sexual harassment problem that
we had because i wasn't i took my eye
off the ball um
and so you know i try to be self-aware
and try to put myself in the shoes of
the person or people or organization i'm
talking about whether it
adds value um i try to put myself in the
position my own position you know how's
it going to be perceived and you know
is it worth it you know will it create
more good
than
challenges right and and so you've got
to pick your spots i also knew that like
of course i'd have to work really really
hard if i was ever going to make it of
course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down on the journey
but i knew if i was gonna make it like
the most important thing came down to me
believing that i could
and for me
you know
and here's the thing a lot of times we
hold ourselves back because we say
things to ourselves like oh i'm not
qualified or oh i feel this like dream
on my heart to whatever it is launch a
podcast whatever it is but it's like oh
but i'm you know don't know how and i
don't know i have no connections and all
the things we tell ourselves and
for me
in a way it almost made no sense that i
created a beauty company right and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry but every time i get still
like for me um and you know no matter
what people believe whether it's they're
hearing the universe talk to them or god
talk to them like for me i hear it
through my own intuition what would you
say is the best advice that you could
give other people from what you learned
about making their first million bucks
so say somebody's making six figures
scaling up and that's just do the math
you know what's what's first of all do
you want to make a million
or do you want to keep a million
they're completely they're like 60
percent difference between those two
questions right so specificity and the
goal you want to make everybody's go
everybody watching is going to make a
million dollars i mean if you live
25 years you're going to make a million
dollars 25 times 40 000 bucks bang you
made a million dollars if that's your
goal so that this is what i talked about
in the 10 actual the goals people are
setting
are incorrect and that's why people give
up on their goals
because
i know so many guys that hit a million
dollars like i've had so many people
come to me and say i hit a million
and i lost the juice
yeah it got comfortable almost yeah a
lot of guys in network marketing tell me
this like i was in network marketing i
became a million dollar producer
just lost it because the goal was wrong
the goal was wrong first of all it
wasn't your goal
anybody's got a million dollar target
it's not your goal you adopted this goal
this idea from somebody else
because the number any number that ends
in zero is a lazy number
the chance is a number ending in zero is
almost mathematical what a great point
what a great point so it's a lazy
concept you just adopted somebody else's
idea i want to be a millionaire would do
you have even done the math do the math
on a million dollars it's no money this
is why people they they like god hate
grant
because your target was a million
you're struggling making 200. you think
a million is impossible
you don't want me to tell you the truth
and the truth is it is no money as soon
as you get it i read the book the
millionaire next door almost everybody
read that book back in the 90s
it was the best book for me
because it taught me
i don't want to be a millionaire
it lifted the lid i'm like i don't want
to be the guy buying a ford truck
i don't want a ford truck man
right i got to buy a ford truck a used
ford truck f-150
so one day i could be a millionaire
and i can't go get coffee i need to
bring a brown pack to my office every
day
not drink coffee at the shop
in order to be a millionaire well the
reason i knew that was not good for me
was because my dad died at 52
with a little bit of money
and i'm like i don't want to die
with money when i'm old
i want to have enough money
and that that undid everything for me i
want financial freedom i don't want to
get a quota
you know and i think everybody's
struggling for the quota they're
struggling for the bills they set their
financial plan based on what their
spending is or what their apartment
costs or what the mortgage is rather or
what their kids need rather than i want
freedom
i don't want financial literacy
i want financial freedom
you know so i hear people say oh we need
to teach financial literacy no you need
to teach financial freedom the
possibility of it what would i need how
much
you know this whole cash flow thing that
i talk about all the time cash flow is
the holy grail of finance
that's why his business works that's why
he's able to enjoy the lifestyle he has
he has
financial freedom not a money number two
weeks ago i went i went uh plant only
plant-based plant-based how does that
feel i dropped the meat dude that's so i
want to do that i did that for a week
last week yeah and i felt amazing i had
a lot more gas just from all the plants
i think but just cleaning it out
that's really too much information for
me
but i've had uh way more energy yeah but
like and less inflammation and less pain
yeah i hadn't noticed i have a little
bit of inflammation in in my hands but
yeah that hadn't hadn't changed but
the plant-based thing i watched the game
the the game changing show yeah
and uh when he said
dude you're eating the middle man
like when i heard that that was enough
for me right eating the middle man
you're eating the middleman
meaning the cow the cow eats the grass
right you can go eat go right
the source is the grass yeah and as soon
as i heard that i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i doing eating the middleman
i ain't a middleman guy i want to go
directly to the source
where all the energy's at yeah i mean
like like any that was the line in the
show that did me and i had been thinking
about it too i've eaten meat for 60
years i grew up on bacon
four pieces of bacon every day so good
uh oh yeah totally
the eggs i i have not eaten any meat
in 12 days
and my energy is
this all day long wow
3 30 in the afternoon for the last 25
years i crashed at 3 30. hard crash i
mean like
i'll see you guys uh call me later okay
what'd you do at 3 30. i got him i got a
meeting yeah that meeting was on that
nap dude and when i hit it i'm talking
coma
deep sleep
better than
sleep at night sometimes it would be 30
minutes sometimes it'd be an hour and a
half
like comatose 12 days i'm i can't take a
nap
i try to go take a nap i cannot fall
asleep
so i'll give my energy do you think
you're going to stick with this do you
think you'll have meat sometimes
i mean i'm not i'm not like i'm not a
fanatic guys so so it's a little meat
here and there or something i'm just
going to eat what makes me feel best
yeah so i don't care if it was meat if
it was pork it was bacon but right now
as long as i can find the greens
and i haven't met i haven't missed the
meat wow
my digestion's better
you know
my energy is great
so
i don't know man
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want even more advice from billionaires
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there i became
terrified of public speaking and uh i
just couldn't do it we don't love this
product but we think others will love it
you know that's not really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with